Oh Kyle ugh and Jackie O you biggest
celebrities in all of Australia Oh what
does your nose go
and every time I come here show you my
penis on eyeballs my husband and what a
good time it is what the [ __ ] going on
here what's your name bro Oh dry me you
can't see what you reading stream I
about that what are you doing what are
you guys
yeah
who wants to see a professional do it
yeah whoa red carpet get here
have you guys ever heard of Lily Allen
because that's whose party we're at yeah
alright we just skip the line in the big
way yeah it's hot with Lily Allen a
steely Allen doesn't have to worry about
a face I might show her my penis
how many key mothers and said Lily Allen
knows you're here and I'm thinking how
cool man she's a bad rat like we have to
meet at Grandma's version
she's like no like she's mom's [ __ ]
great please thank movie Oliver Woodlawn
all right but before this before I get
stuck here for ages
yes you're quick oh my God look at all
these [ __ ] people like all everything
for me you should have seen innovation
your slaves the last of my life the last
of my flesh and the pride of this world
and I was a child of the devil as many
of you are
Australian music taking you to me how
much does a pack of cigarettes cost
I don't want any but I'm just curious
how much impact of it doesn't say
Marlboro 2055 those twenty dollars and
fifty thousand in Australian dollar is
the same as an American dollar or the 93
cents yeah 93 94 which all the
cigarettes are locked up behind that and
still people be $20 per back
people are [ __ ] stupid if you lock up
all the cigarettes huh why don't I just
want to know how [ __ ] stupid you had
to be to pay twenty dollars for a pack
of cigarettes
pretty dumb like it would be any smarter
spirits from chief now the Australian
elevator I maximum pelion hundred
dollars that's hardly more than a pack
is here alright my you Tom have a Gowan
Mike another taxi Mike how long you been
driving in Sydney Mike oh yeah [ __ ]
long time there this is done 75 [ __ ] Fox
yeah wouldn't you [ __ ] answer the
phone mud okay moving and now you really
hate traffic don't you hate that man I
don't want to walk in sit down and walk
in the city
Wow I don't normally think babies are
cute but that baby's [ __ ] here this
is a very scenic spot for a hacky sack
trick
get one